في اليوم الاول للاهدنا الرابعه نلحق تدفق
عدد كبير جدا من المواطنين الى الشوارع
الرئيسيه نحن الان في شارع الستين في جنوب
الخرطوم وتشاهدون عدد
مقدر من المواطنين جاؤوا بامتعتهم جاءوا
بحقائبهم للخروج من العاصمه الخرطوم هذه
المنطقه ليست هي موقف للبساط السفريه
وانما جاء اهل الباصات السفريه باعتبارها
انها هي المخرج الى جنوب الخرطوم حيث
الولايات الاخرى مثل مدني والطريق ايضا
الى بورسودان والى القضارف والى كسلا والى
عدد من ولايات السودان المختلفه مشاكل
التي يواجهها المواطنين حسب ما تحدثنا لهم
هو وجود السيوله النقديه سيول النقديه غير
متوفر بسبب ان كل المصارف الان هي خارج
الخدمه
وبالتالي ليست بايديهم اموال حتى
يقدم لاصحاب الباصات السفريه تحدثنا معهم
وتحدث اللغه عنها استغلال من قبل اهل
الباصات السفريه بحيث ان الاسعار ارتفعت
الى عشره اضعافها والى الى او الى خمسه
فمثلا اذا تحدثنا عن سعر
تذكره التذكره الى مدينه بورسودان وصل الى
200 الف جنيه سوداني اي 400 دولار وسعر
التذكره الى الى معبر الى اسوان الى اكثر
من
250 او 200
وخمسين الف جنيه اي نحو تقريبا نحو 500
دولار وبالتالي هذه الارقام هي جنونيه
اصحاب الباصات يتحدثون ان السبب وراء
ارتفاع هذه الاسعار يرجع الى عامينين
العامل الاول ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات
وندرتها العامل الثاني هو المخاطره التي
يخاطرونها في الطريق الى هذه المنطقه
في اليوم الاول في الهدنه الرابعه هناك
تدفق في مناطق جنوب الخرطوم هناك امل في
ان يخرج الناس من هذه
المناطق التي تشهد اشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع محمد
الطيب الجزيره
جنوب الخرطوم